[Music]
welcome back to next episode of what's
up prof
hello again walter good day how are you
doing
i see we're both little boys blue today
yeah but good birds of the feather flock
together
uh you look a little bit tired
have you had a loss of sleep in the last
few days sleep is a luxury let's put it
that way
no you look fit as a fiddle so can you
open up for us with a word of prayer
absolutely
heavenly father we need you
more and more as the world ends up in
turmoil
it is necessary lord that we stay very
close to you
and we pray that you will stay very
close to us
enlighten us with your spirit give us
the right thoughts
and right words to speak in jesus name
amen
amen yes a lot has happened
in the recent few weeks
and i think it's time that we again get
some updates
on what's happening in the world
and will you guide us in this whole
discussion today because there's a lot
of articles that we're going to be
discussing yes and um i think
over to you well not only over to me
even to you too
you're not going to get off this side
get off this lightly
well let's have a look at some of these
interesting things just to get
a link to where we were we were
discussed the covet 19
pandemic and all of these things in the
past so
let's just link it to that and see where
we're heading
because if there is an agenda and if
there is a plan
something must be unfolding it can't
just be
haphazard uh your attention is directed
towards the chaos
so that you don't see the line
of rational thinking behind it
but we have to look past the scenes of
history
and see what's going on behind the
scenes exactly of history exactly
just to give us that link
this is a very interesting magazine the
economist
and in 2019 they brought
out this particular one over here
and it's a very interesting one because
if you know where the economist
comes from and who runs it it's a very
influential
magazine and it only comes out
approximately once a year
so yeah someone wrote about it this is
not them writing
so why would anyone spend time
deciphering these covers
well this person says because the
economist isn't just any publication it
is directly connected with the world's
elite
it is a part it is partly owned by the
rothschild banking family in
england and its editor-in-chief john
michael
has attended the bilderberg conference
several times in short the leadership of
the economist has
inside knowledge of the elite's agenda
and they do their best to promote it
that's just someone's opinion
so let's just have a look at their
official explanation
they say the world in 2019 will build on
three decades of publishing success
this will be the 33rd edition i made
that bold
it will look ahead to the trump
administration's prospects
with a new congress the reality of
brexit elections in india
indonesia nigeria and across europe tech
disruptions from
ai and china 2019
mark peak silicon valley space travel
50 years after the moon landing and
culture
500 years of the leonardo da vinci
now if we know how the occult world
works
then there are a couple of interesting
things in this little paragraph number
one the 33
the 33rd edition and the masonic 33
degrees of course is always very
prominent
and they also love jubilees yeah
remember when we had the reformation the
500 years of the reformation
everything was about jubilee and it was
the 50th year of
dialogue and the this and the 50 and the
500s now we have very similar thing here
you have the 50 years after the moon
landing
and culture 500 years after leonardo da
vinci
of course was a brilliant man but he was
also an esoterically inclined individual
all right so why are there such odd
things on this
cover for example the writing
is all reverse
it's mirror writing mirror image
and why would that be well
the occult uses reverse
writing aleister crowley used to
teach his disciples to speak backwards
walk backwards etc everything was
in reverse so in esoteric thinking
when you reverse something then
the the real meaning comes to the fall
so good becomes evil and evil becomes
good
for example if you reverse it jesus
christ in the bible would become the
devil
and the devil would become christ
so if you take a
a bible study document like a
concordance or something
in the esoteric world then you have all
of these reverse
features in it so there is reverse
writing on here
and we're not going to discuss all of
these images
as i said people can look them up on the
way but there are one or two that are
rather fascinating of course there is
this famous
image here of leonardo's
where he is slightly modified he has
glasses on there which probably
look like 3d virtual reality
virtual reality glasses there's a
a tattoo of dna on his arm
there's a cannabis implant in his hand
there's a cell phone in his hand there
are scales in his hands
and there's a symbol towards sports
there are many other things over here
angelina jolie
is depicted over here in a mona lisa
style we're not going to go into those
details but there are some things that
are really interesting
obviously donald trump
and putin are in this picture
and then you have over there recognition
written backwards so facial recognition
is going to be an important thing
artificial intelligence is going to be
an important thing
they even have pinocchio over there
which is of course was also a masonic
writer
and the fact that his nose here is
depicted in this
long way could be an indication of
deception
lying for example but
i don't want to discuss any of these
issues
people can make their own studies i'm
interested
in this little portion over here
and that's what i want to just say one
or two two
things about these are the writers of
the apocalypse
so if we'll just enlarge them a little
this was in 2019
the first thing that that appears is
that they are in reverse order
everything is backwards right so
in the riders of the apocalypse when the
seals are opened
the first one should be the rider on the
white horse who is the king who has
a crown on his head yes and this is
in the book of revelation the depiction
of
the gospel going to the world white
righteousness of christ christ going out
to conquer
and then of course it depicts the battle
as it
unfolds and then you have the red horse
and then you have the black horse and
then you have
the pale horse which is dead now here
they are in reverse order
so the parallels death
then you have the black horse and then
you have
this horse which would depict the red
horse
now red is the color of sacrifice in the
bible right
but here it is depicted as a statue of
liberty and i find it fascinating that
she has something on her face yes
and that something is a mask
this was 2019 this was before covert 19
right
yes this is in the beginning of 2019 i
think when the magazine comes out
so this is very interesting and of
course she has this crown on the head
which is a corona
yeah it's also the sign of mithraism
and then you have the king so if you put
it in reverse order
then instead of the king going out and
bringing the gospel of righteousness to
the world
and then the counter
actions by the devil take place and the
gospel
is hindered more and more first it is
the martyrdom and then it is
the blackness and the darkness of the
middle ages finally leading
to virtual death right
so in in occult thinking
if you turn it around who will be the
conqueror in the end
if the one that was to go out to
bring the pure message was to be the
king and he's here depicted as dead
then the conqueror would be their
esoteric king which would be lucifer
yes so that's a reversal but i thought
it fascinating
that this magazine brings out the united
states
in a in a central role before the coming
of the false messiah yes
in a covet 19 mosque very interesting
so if there is a logic behind the chaos
where is all of this heading
well we would have to look at
legislation
we would have to look at events leading
to legislation
and to changes and we would have to
speculate to a large extent
who the puppet masters are yes
or is everything just chaotic and
there's no meaning to anything yes
that's the other possibility right we
would like to
see what's the signs of the times
in happening in the world and is it
leading
to the soon coming of jesus absolutely
that is what we are supposed to do
we are to place the events of history
into the prophetic picture to see where
we are standing in the stream of time
yes all right let us just look at this
facial recognition
uh issue it's interesting that they
should put this in there
and you can see the reverse writing over
there and then they also had
this picture here with the cell phone
with a barcode with a barcode on it
so what is important here is can we see
the finger of rome in
all of these issues facial recognition
and the technology that is available
because
basically this technology is about
control
because we can see it in china right the
is being used to control the people they
even get
points whereby if they
accumulate a certain number of points
they may not
take part in certain activities like
travel etc
so in 2016 already the pope met with
the big tech companies to discuss some
of these issues
so continuing his dialogue with leaders
in the world of social media and
technology
pope francis met with facebook founder
and ceo
mark zuckerman and earlier this year the
pope met with several
notable tech giants so definitely they
have their finger on the pulse
in the world's mobile communications
including eric smith and apple ceo tim
cook
he also met with kevin sustrom ceo and
co-founder of
instagram two weeks before the vatican
launched the pope's
instagram account francisco's
upon its launch the account broke a new
record for gaining over 1 million
followers in 12 hours he's a popular man
yes pro france's twitter account
at pontifex has also left its mark in
the social media landscape
with over 30 million followers spread
across
nine different language accounts
diplomacy
a study of twitter accounts of world
leaders and their retweet rates declared
the pope
by far the most influential
leader on twitter that's very
interesting
especially when you compare um
trump he uses twitter all the time
all the time then you must know how
popular the pope is
so it seems as if the beast out of this
the sea
and the beast out of the earth are
very clued up when it comes to the use
of this technology
after these meetings it's interesting
that these
tech giants started introducing new
rules
yes let's have a look at some of these
it describes hateful content when it
comes to hate speech
as any video that promotes
discrimination
or disparages or humiliates people on
the basis of their race
ethnicity nationality
religion that's very interesting so if
you say
something derogatory about
someone's religion that is hate speech
so would it qualify if you said that
one of these religious systems is an
antichrist system
i think it would i think it would
qualify
disability age veteran status
sexual orientation gender identity or
other characteristics associated with
systemic discrimination
so they're differently bringing in
a a code of morality which is
based on hate-speech legislation
well if you can take in the they
the tech giants went to the pope
afterwards you got some rules in their
way of dealing with videos being posted
or any comments being posted on
instagram or
youtube i mean even the children's that
whole children
children's act came in on youtube yes
and all of these things happened
and then the social media started
taking off videos especially youtube
they started
censoring yes they started being a
censorship
and then what's interesting is recently
there was a clash with trump yes they
even tried to
remove some of his tweets and then
decided not to etc
yeah so it's interesting that trump
signs an executive order
to combat social media censorship
so we're having this interplay in other
words what this does of course
is makes the moral issue prominent
how far are we going to
allow things to progress
in order to prevent fermentation
of conflict in society
in other words what they're really
aiming for is a set of
rules which will limit speech
to the point that conflict can be
prevented
by legislation trump has accused twitter
of interfering in the 2020 presidential
election
and social media platforms generally of
silencing
conservative voices he warned social
media giants that his administration
could strongly regulate or close them
down
now isn't that interesting he complains
that there's no free speech but then
he strongly he says he can strongly
regulate and close them down as well
absolutely so in the one hand he wants
free speech but then
he can close you down if you don't agree
with if he doesn't agree with so what
has basically happened
the issue has been made prominent that's
what
it's all about
okay how far does this go the pope has
joined with
microsoft and ibm to create a doctrine
for ethical
ai artificial intelligence microsoft and
ibm
joined pope francis in endorsing the
document
according to writers the document also
said ai
tools should work fairly transparently
reliably and with respect for human life
and the environment so who's taking the
moral high ground here
yes and as soon as they
start introducing legislation which
favors the moral high ground of the
papacy
then power is given unto the beast
there's a recognition of his authority
as the moral compass of the world
and this is where it's heading and this
is
an image of the beast forming before
our very eyes
pope francis wants to see facial
recognition
artificial intelligence and other
powerful new technologies
follow a doctrine of ethical
and moral principles and i'm sure
everybody wants that
yes and isn't it wonderful that there is
a voice that stands up for this
and that the tech giants are listening
to this voice
so is an image to the beast forming
is the papacy the moral compass of the
world
now the book of revelation also tells us
that
humanity will be very closely regulated
because if you do not accept the mark of
the beast
you will not be able to perform certain
functions like buying and selling for
example
how will that be regulated now remember
that
da vinci had the cell phone in the hand
and it had a barcode on it how is that
being utilized in the world
already and how is that legislation
being introduced now here's an
interesting article from the japan
times talks about green or red light and
there's a lady
and she has a cell phone in her hand and
she's pointing at a board
to enter many offices restaurants parks
or malls in china nowadays
people must show their status on an app
that determines whether they are a
coronavirus threat
now this is just the beginning you could
have
in that app many other parameters
besides coronavirus
for example your ideology could that
become
part of the app if rome dictates to this
software giants what the morality is
i think it's pretty so it's pretty
possible right so a green light lets you
in anywhere
so you want to go shopping we're talking
about buying and selling yes
about being an economic entity in the
world
a yellow light could send you into
home confinement the dreaded red light
throws a person into a strict two-week
quarantine at the hotel
you don't even get to go home and this
is already implemented and already
implemented
many chinese people say they are happy
to cooperate for the greater good
common good yes the apps have become
a necessity for travel in china to book
train or plane tickets or enter many
public places
though not all establishments require
them
such as supermarkets but that could
change
yes it allows authorities to look back
at someone's travel history in the
previous 14 days
and see if they visited areas considered
high risk
or were exposed to anyone with covet 19
so in china this is already a reality
in switzerland it has not yet been
approved but if approved
the swiss app will be optional and no
personal data or location information
will be used
so the government says in france
the stop covert app being developed
would allow users who become
sick to anonymously alert people
they may have come across it would not
use
gps location technology britain
is also trialling a new phone app to
identify
localized outbreaks so this is becoming
international
yes it's going to be worldwide
so there is a monitoring system that is
developing
and this is precisely what scripture
tells us
new rules making healthy people
self-isolate could quickly become
mandatory you see the net
is closing in the uk health minister
hancock repeated the possibility of the
system becoming
mandatory in an interview this morning
on sky news saying that there are powers
that we
took through parliament at the start of
the crisis
in the coronavirus act to be able to
mandate this
so this is jumping the gun they have
already
prepared the legislation so
we are heading towards a totalitarian
regime worldwide worldwide
there's another one from the washington
post apple and google launch
coronavirus exposure software
so technology is going to play a very
major role and seeing that there is
facial recognition which can pick out
the face
in a massive crowd there is no way to
hide it it brings
to to mind some of these uh
hollywood movies where this kind of
technology was sort of pre-figured enemy
of the state for example
and all of those not that you should be
watching them
but they are indicators of
where we are going after all they are
jesuit theater right
correct so what's interesting on this
one
is state and federal governments can
use it to create contact tracing apps
that citizens can download via apple
app store or the google play store
so what we are experiencing is the rise
of surveillance technology
and surveillance technology will play a
central part in control of populations
and who gets to do whatever
is deemed appropriate
by the powers that be and who is going
to be excluded
now in any totalitarian regime
surveillance is absolutely essential
in hitler's time you had
this massive surveillance system where
everybody was watching everybody else
if you go to communist systems
they had a massive surveillance system
this comes a long way already herod the
great
was renowned for his surveillance system
so now with this technology it is
interesting to see
how they have grown here's a document
which tells us that the net worth of
america's 600
plus billionaires has increased by more
than
400 billion during the pandemic
so while everybody is going down these
people are
coming up i wonder whether these are
some of the merchants of the world
that in revelation chapter 18
will decry the fall of babylon
i think we are moving in that you know
what's interesting is the top
ones of these billionaires most of them
are also tech company owners
yes that's just interesting yes how
their net worth has grown
to 75.5 and the name
reads like the who's who jeff bezos bill
gates
mark zuckerberg warren buffett larry
ellison
this is interesting now
the spirit of prophecy has something to
say on these issues
we read in manuscript 135 written in
under the title instructions to the
church
that the church is to be built on jesus
christ the only true foundation
let us beware that it is not marred in
the building
by the introduction of worthless
material that will not
bear the test of trial those who desire
to possess
characters that will make them laborers
together with god
worthy of receiving his commendation
must separate themselves from the
enemies of god
in all places stand firm for truth
christ is concerned with the heart
he's concerned about our characters
never does he coerce or control
he allows you freedom of choice any
system
that needs to control morality
by force of legislation
is displaying a bankruptcy
there will be more and still more
external
parade by worldly powers we see it in
the world today
under different symbols god presented to
john the wicked character and seductive
influence of those who have been
distinguished for their persecution of
his people
this is referring to the roman catholic
system and
its persecution through the inquisition
etc the 18th chapter of revelation
speaks of mystic babylon fallen from a
higher state to become a persecuting
power
those who keep the commandments of god
and have the faith of jesus are the
object
of the wrath of this power so this is
exactly where
all of this is leading yes so what
should our attitude be
should we be involved or should
we stand back and observe
we have to obey government legislation
as far as it does not contravene
god's law law
john writes after these things i saw
another angel come down from heaven
having great power and the earth was
lighted by his glory
and he cried mightily with a strong
voice saying babylon the great is fallen
is fallen he's become the habitation of
devils
and the hold of every fowl spirit and a
cage of every unclean and hateful bird
for all the nations have drunk of the
wine of the wrath of her fornication
have swallowed her doctrines
yes her morality in other words
and the kings of the earth have
committed fornication with her
in other words they have been adulterous
they have left the true witness which is
christ
and followed another system and the
merchants of the earth
are waxed rich through the abundance of
her delicacies
well we've seen riches increase
dramatically yes
whereas the rest of humanity seems to be
coming poverty-struck that's true and
there's kings
also that's mingling with this roman
power
absolutely this terrible picture drawn
by john
to show how completely the powers of
earth will give themselves over to evil
should so those who have received the
truth how
dangerous it is to link up with secret
societies
or to join themselves in any way with
those who do not keep god's commandments
i don't think there is any doubt that
secret societies
are at play here if you
if you look at the interplay the
hegelian dialectic
of some of these billionaires i mean
take
donald trump he is super rich
and on the other hand you have soros
who is also super rich and apparently
they are fighting on opposite sides yes
or so it seems right or is it a hygiene
hegelian dialectic to bring us to a
particular point
let us see how far this
really goes the national catholic
reporter
tells us that france's appointment of
jesuits to lead the vatican officers an
anomaly in the church's history
and then it tells us that he has
appointed
members of the society of jesus in key
positions within the church in other
words they've taken control
of the church now what was the aim of
the jesuits
wasn't it to overthrow protestantism
and to bring the whole world back into
subjection to the papacy
that is the aim yes and since we're
talking about the economy
it's interesting that the three highest
positions are now held within the
vatican
by the jesuits and the latest was the
spanish
jesuit father juan guerrero alves
who the pope appointed in november 14 to
become
the prefect of the secretariat for the
economy
so the jesuits are in control
of these issues and the economy of
course is part of the system
of babylon in revelation chapter 18.
now in the book great controversy on
page 232
we read throughout christendom
protestantism was menaced by
formidable foes the first triumphs of
the reformation passed
rome summoned new forces hoping to
accomplish its destruction
at this time the order of the jesuits
was created
the most cruel unscrupulous
and powerful of all the champions of
purpurey
cut off from earthly ties and human
interests dead to the claims of natural
affection
reason and conscience wholly silenced
they knew no rule no tie but that of
their order and
no duty but to extend its power
is this something that is just part of a
dismal history
or is this still a reality today that is
a question we need to ask ourselves
i think it's a very important question
because we see jesuits popping up
everywhere now in both sides of both
sides
yes it's in rome it's in the and then
you when you see the hegelian dialectic
like you've just mentioned
they're in the white house
they're in churches and they're shouting
on either side absolutely i gave a
lecture many years ago
which was called revolution tyrants and
wars
where i showed how the jesuits
were instrumental in
most of the fermentations in the world
the cataclysms and we are heading for
a time of anarchy such as never was
which is going to be akin to that which
happened in the french revolution
yes and uh i mean there were videos
where these crowds
were running around with guillotines
isn't that yes i think in puerto rico
yes yes puerto rico they've even got a
guillotine
that they're taking around these are
symbols of the french
revolution and the whole world is going
to be engulfed in a
similar convulsion and the jesuits
if they have so much practice in history
of fermenting these things why would
they not
be at the forefront of everything today
and we see them there
so the gospel of christ had enabled its
adherence to meet danger and endure
suffering
undismayed by cold hunger toil and
poverty
to uphold the banner of truth in the
face of the rack the dungeon and the
stake
to combat these forces jesuitism
inspired its followers with the
fanaticism that enabled them to endure
like dangers
and to oppose to the power of truth all
the weapons of deception
this is what the jesuit exercises were
for
the ignacian exercises
there was no crime too great for them to
commit
no deception to base for them to
practice
no disguise too difficult for them to
assume
vowed to perpetual poverty and humility
it was their studied aim to secure
wealth and power to be devoted to the
overthrow of protestantism
and the re-establishment of the papal
supremacy
that is their aim that's them the
catholic hero
reports that the papacy's plan
which they call god's plan
is to unite all humanity
now the bible clearly says that god's
kingdom is not of this world
and this world is in enmity
to god so if you unite
all of humanity is it going to be united
on the side of god
or is it going to be united on the other
side
there were of course attempts in the
past to unite humanity
and to keep it united and god separated
them
it's also interesting that if you study
the bible
the new jerusalem the different nations
will enter
at different gates so i i'm wondering
whether this is
really so when you go to the tower of
babel
the whole earth was of one language and
of one speech and it came to pass as
they journeyed from the east that they
found a plane in the land of
shinar that's babylon
and they dwelt there and they said
one to another go two let us make brick
and burn them thoroughly
and they had brick for stone and slime
bitumen or
and they said go too let us build us a
city and a tower whose top may reach
unto heaven
and let us make us a name lest we be
scattered abroad upon the face of the
whole earth
the very essence of that was discontent
and unbelief god had already promised
that he would not
destroy the world with a flood again and
they built the tower
to prevent them from being destroyed
the search for christian unity is making
progress
says the pope yes the previous
article was stated
by pope francis in the beginning of his
papacy
this is now the 26th of may this year
okay marking the 25th anniversary of
saint john paul's encyclical
on christian unity pope francis said
he shares the healthy impatience
of those who think more can and should
be done
but he also insisted that christians
must be grateful for the progress
made many steps have been taken in these
decades to heal the wounds
very interesting terminology very
of centuries and millennia pope francis
said
in the encyclical saint john paul
reaffirmed the catholic church's
irrevocable commitment to working and
praying for christian unity highlighted
how
christians of all denominations
already are united in the experience of
martyrdom called for efforts to promote
a healing
of historical memories and mutual
forgiveness this is almost
biblical language correct on the reverse
side
because this healing of the wound will
lead
to a setting up of the image of
the beast yes the terminology is amazing
so we go to the book of revelation it
says
and i saw one of his heads as it were
wounded to death
and his deadly wound was healed
and all the world wandered after the
beast
and i beheld another beast come up out
of the earth and it had two horns like a
lamb
and he spoke as a dragon so this
lamb-like beast
the united states of america the symbol
of
protestantism in the world will
eventually speak like the dragon
how did the dragon speak it was
a totalitarian regime it used the state
to enforce its dogmas
so here again we will have a similar
system church and state
yes and he does great wonders so that he
makes fire come down from heaven on the
earth in the sight of men
this is the charisma coming down
and deceiveth them that dwell on the
earth so this is a deceptive religion
so protestantism from a
purely word-based religion
changes into an experienced based
religion
and then the norm becomes the experience
and that is very dangerous because the
word
should be the basis of your darkness
not the experience that is why
the world is deceived into believing
that the spirit of god is working
mightily
yes but when the spirit leads away from
the law and the testimony
then you have a problem so there's unity
but the unity
is because of this spiritual experience
and not according to unity because of
what the bible says correct if you take
some of the experiences within the
christian community you have very
similar
experiences in non-christian religions
so when the experience becomes the norm
then unity
is possible but christ will be crucified
again
right in the beginning of donald trump's
presidency
he actually met with pope francis and
it's interesting that
the jesuits in britain spoke about this
and the hopes for peace and dialogue
and the gifts that they exchanged were
interesting
a small sculptured olive tree as a
symbol of peace
but how does this peace come about is it
order
out of chaos donald trump is such an
interesting individual
and his religious affiliations are
rather fascinating so he visits the pope
he proclaims to be a presbyterian in
other words of the calvinistic
mindset but politico magazine gave us a
little bit of an
insight and said who his mentors were
and his mentor according to them
was norman vincent peale
now norman vincent peale of course was a
33 degree freemason
and i actually took a picture
of a painting of his with the signature
33 degree
masonic signature underneath and i took
that picture in the 33rd
lodge the 33 degree lodge in washington
and that's another story it's in in
other lectures
yes but let's see what donald trump said
about him
i still remember peel's sermons trump
told the
iowa family leadership summit in july
you could listen to him all day long and
when you left the church you were
disappointed it was over
he was the greatest guy a month later in
the same news conference at which trump
tossed out
univision anchor george ramos he again
referred to peel
as his pastor and he says he was one of
the greatest
speakers he'd ever seen
norman vincent peale of course was also
the hero of robert schuller
and the whole modern christian movement
in the united states so you have a very
deep masonic connection
there known as god salesman
peel merged worldliness and godliness to
produce an
easy to follow theology that preached
self-confidence as a life philosophy
now this is actually an anti-christian
doctrine
because we are taught in the bible to
depend upon christ whereas the new age
movement
and the awkward world tells you that you
have this divinity
inside of you you must just dig deep
enough to find it
and to pick yourself up by your socks
yourself
yeah this is roman catholic doctrine at
its very core that
you are responsible for your own
salvation
in terms of finding this obedience
within yourself
critics call him a con man described his
church as a cult and said his
simple-minded approach
shut off genuine thinking or insight but
peel's outlook promoted through his
radio shows
newspaper columns and articles and
through guideposts his monthly digest of
inspirational messages
fit perfectly into the trump family
culture
of never hesitating to bend the rules
doing whatever it took to win and never
ever giving up so the power of positive
thinking
not the power of submitting to christ
and there are many photographs which
show this connection
so he has trump at the norman vincent
peale 90th birthday party in 1988
so they obviously had strong connections
i find his latest stunts fascinating
remember what prophecy says
that protestantism would form an image
to the beast
that protestantism would give their
power
unto the beast the kings of the world
will give their power unto the beast in
other words they will again
acknowledge papal supremacy and lend the
power of the state
in order to further the aims of the
papacy
and anybody who didn't go along with
that would be persecuted that's the
biblical narrative right
so you have this power on the one hand
which
elevates humanity and you have the power
on the other hand which elevates christ
now which one are you going to obey now
are there any signs
that they are really working to joining
protestantism and catholicism
in a powerful union that will again
persecute god's people in the end we've
already seen in the previous articles
that rome has got its fingers in almost
everything and the stage all the
technologies the big tech
they want to put a doctrine in for how
to regulate these things so
let's and the kings of the world have
all visited the papacy
and the great conferences as to how the
education will be
conducted in the future will take place
in rome right
in october now here's an interesting
development and i find this one
fascinating
the bbc reported george floyd death
trump's church
visit shocks religious leaders here he's
seen
with his bible in his hand last night
he held a bible in front of saint john's
episcopal church just across the road
from the white house
today he'll visit the shrine of saint
john paul ii
also in washington dc so here you have
a protestant and a catholic action
the bible is being held up this is the
standard of protestantism
so they're saying very well now the
episcopal church
of course is
like the church of england basically and
they have moved very largely in
a roman catholic liturgy direction
unlike the rest of protestantism which
hasn't gone that far
yet but here's basically the link
between protestantism
and catholicism and then
he went to the shrine
of john paul ii
now this is amazing and here is a
picture that was released by the press
but these the ones that were on their
private
uh communications were even more
fascinating
as the catholic news service trump
visits shrine on the anniversary of
saint john paul
ii visit to poland and trump signed an
executive order during the noon hour
that the white house described as
prioritizing u.s
support for religious freedom worldwide
again we must qualify that the papacy
has declared that you only have
religious freedom
in that it serves the common good yes
and that we should not forget now
there was a lot of opposition to what he
did
to these visits and both from
protestants
and from catholics
this one comes from their private
communications donald trump and the
first lady melania
knelt in prayer behind the scenes during
their visit to the saint john
paul ii national shrine in washington dc
on tuesday
a behind-the-scenes photo posted on
melania trump's instagram
showed the trump's kneeling in prayer
inside the shrine
would a protestant do that would a
protestant
go and kneel in the shrine or
dedicated to a catholic saint
apparently we can apparently yes
is this a signal
that a protestant president is willing
to bow
down and bow the knee to catholic
principles
are we seeing a closing of the gap
i i think so you have to be blind not to
see this you have to be blind right
definitely so is an image to the beast
beginning to form
it's so blatantly in front of our eyes
i don't understand why some people can
just not see this
i don't understand it either but we have
very prominent people saying there is no
image to the beast forming
yes and everywhere i look in the media i
see the image of the beast forming i
don't know do i have different glasses
is there something wrong with these
maybe i must clean it a little bit
better
now this is the most interesting thing
that has happened in the media
yes of late this letter
and it's from the from june the 6th 2020
by archbishop
vigano's powerful letter to president
trump
now we just saw in the previous ones
that some of the bishops were heavily
criticizing donald trump
and here is another one who is playing
the opposite role
he is praising the president but this
letter to me is almost prophetic
i agree i think we should spend a little
bit of time on this
definitely archbishop carlo maria
avigano
warns the president that the current
crisis of the coronavirus pandemic
and the george floyd riot are part of
the eternal
spiritual struggle between the forces of
good and evil
this is this is a very interesting
statement
now of course there are many web pages
that say
that this george floyd
incident was a false flag there are web
pages that claim
that this was staged that there were
very similar events
in the united states with very similar
occurrences
in france for example and that there are
forces behind
the scenes that are fermenting racial
conflict and this fits in with the chaos
that they want and the anarchy to bring
about
whatever their world order is now it's
not our place to say
whether this is so or whether it is not
so
it's just interesting to know that these
things are happening yes
now another point that's very important
is as followers of christ
what should our position be it's a
critical
point that you're mentioning yes what
should our position be i think it's very
important
do we become involved politically
on this point or that point
or do we as ambassadors
for christ stand for righteousness and
truth
that if you are a christian there should
be no room
in your heart for discriminating
against anyone on whatever basis
you are an ambassador for christ and you
are to bring the gospel
of salvation you are to sow the seed
what people do with the seed is
their business all have sinned and fall
short of the glory of god
the seed must be sown to all classes
there must be no
discrimination what happens to that seed
is not your business
that's god's business but in heaven
there will be perfect harmony and nobody
will esteem or deem
someone greater than someone else
so we should not be involved in any of
these political issues we're very clear
directives in the spirit of prophecy
that we are not to be involved yes so
you don't even know are these real or
are they fake news
exactly we don't even know so let us
just do our christian duty
and let us be kind to all people
and let us preach the gospel that is our
duty and not get sidetracked
no don't get sidetracked so what does he
say in recent months
we have been witnessing the formation of
two
opposing sides that i would call
biblical
the children of light and the children
of darkness
in an apparent inexplicable way the good
are held hostage by the wicked
and by those who help them either out of
self-interest
or fearfulness these two sides which
have a biblical nature follow the clear
separation between the offspring of the
woman
and the offspring of the serpent now so
far i can go
along with this i can conquer right
on the one hand there are those who
although they have a
thousand defects and weaknesses are
motivated by the desire to do good to be
honest to raise a family
to engage in work to give prosperity to
their homeland
to help the needy in an obedience to the
law of god
that's interesting which law the one in
the bible or the one
in the papal books well is a papal
bishop
so obviously he's referring to the roman
catholic version and not the biblical
version
to merit the kingdom of heaven on the
other hand there are those who serve
themselves who do not hold
any moral principles who want to
demolish the family and the nation
exploit workers to make themselves
unduly wealthy
ferment internal divisions and wars
and accumulate power and money for them
the fallacious
illusion of temporal well-being will one
day if they do not repent
yield to the terrible faith that awaits
them
far from god in eternal damnation
in society mr president these two
opposing
realities coexist as eternal enemies
do you agree with that yes well there
are eternal enemies
up till now but there will come an end
exactly
it's not a yin-yang system they will
come an
end to this animosity and god
will clean up the mess
just as god and satan are eternal
enemies
and it appears that the children of
darkness whom we may easily identify
with the deep state
so now he's talking donald trump
language yes
which you wisely oppose and which is
fiercely waging war
against you in these days have decided
to show their cards so to speak
by now revealing their plans
they seem to be so certain of already
having
everything under control that they have
laid aside
that circumspection that until now had
at least
partially concealed their true
intentions
the investigations already underway will
reveal the true responsibility of those
who manage
the covet emergency not only in the area
of health care but also in politics the
economy
and the media we will probably find that
in this colossal
operation of social engineering there
are people who have decided the fate of
humanity
arrogating to themselves the right to
act against the will of citizens
and their representatives in the
government
of nations this is interesting
because as we have seen many of those
are
actually jesuit trained individuals yes
and we will also discover that the riots
in these days were provoked by those
seeing that the virus is inevitably
fading and that the social alarm of the
pandemic
is waning necessarily it had to provoke
civil disturbances because they would be
followed by repression
which although legitimate could be
condemned as an
unjustified aggression against the
population i wonder who he's referring
to
is he referring to soros for example
and is he running with this narrative of
the deep state
so he's playing the trumpet on the side
of donald trump
this is very interesting it sounds like
he might
be reading up or be part of the q anons
absolutely the same thing
another point of course is the world out
there says there's no conspiracy
but here is this archbishop speaking
conspiratorial language
in the plainest way yes
amazing the same thing is also happening
in europe
in perfect synchrony you know things
don't happen by chance
exactly all of a sudden everywhere
around the world at the same time
exactly it is quite clear that the use
of street protests
is instrumental to the purpose of those
who would like to see someone elected in
the upcoming presidential elections
who embodies the goals of the deep state
and who expresses those goals faithfully
and with conviction
it will not be surprising if in a few
months we learn
once again that hidden behind these acts
of vandalism and violence
there are those who hope to profit from
the dissolution of the social order
so as to build a world without freedom
salve coagula as the masonic address
teachers although it may seem
disconcerting
the opposing alignments i've described
are also found in religious circles
it is not surprising that these
mercenaries are allies of the children
of darkness and hate the children of
light
just as there is a deep state there is
also a
deep church and we've spoken about that
we have this notion that you have the
liberal side
and then you have the conservative side
even in catholicism catholicism yes so
there are
web pages that speak about this kind of
thing
so the deep church that portrays its
duties and forswears its proper
commitments before god
thus the invisible enemy whom good
rulers
fight against in public affairs is also
fought against by the good
shepherds in the ecclesiastical sphere
so he counts himself
i think as a good shepherd yes and the
good shepherd within catholicism
is against the deep state and donald
trump has made it pretty clear who he
thinks the deep state is right
correct for the first time the united
states has
in you a president who courageously
defends the right to life
who is not ashamed to denounce the
persecution of christians throughout the
world
who speaks of jesus christ and the right
of citizens to freedom of worship
i believe that the attack to which you
were subjected after your visit to the
national shrine of saint john paul ii
is part of the orchestrated media
narrative which seeks not to fight
racism and bring
social order but to aggravate
dispositions
not to bring justice but to legitimize
violence and crime not to serve the
truth
but to favor one political faction
they are subservient to the deep state
to globalism to align
thought to the new world order which
they invoke
ever more frequently in the name of
universal brotherhood which has
nothing christian about it but which
evokes the masonic ideals of those
want to dominate the world by driving
god
out of the courts out of the schools out
of the families and perhaps even
out of the churches so here you have
this is fascinating because i can't
believe
it's a actually a roman archbishop that
wrote this no it's
it's hegelian dialectic at its best so
you have these two opposing sites
and everybody is waiting for this
champion
and when this champion comes and saves
christianity
then they'll be jumping from the frying
pan into the fire
because they will accept this law
of god this roman catholic version of
the law of god
they will accept this morality
and at the same time they will accept
everything that goes along with it
including the surveillance
and both sides would become
equally oppressive
so as we said there's this
morality and the law of god is being
mentioned and this law of god of course
contains the fourth commandment
which says remember the sabbath day
and that the seventh day is the sabbath
but the papal sabbath
is the sunday so by making a choice to
honor the papal sunday
i am accepting the authority of the
papal system
over the word of god so where is this
heading
jubilee for the earth looking to lodato
c
week this comes from the independent
catholic news
and it's from may 10th yes 2020
on the care for our common home we've
been through this so many times but it's
interesting that they wanted jubilee for
the earth
and it's the theme of autumn sedum of
creation and the creation sunday
in september will be introduced
it's interesting yes subtly yeah
just yeah bring it in sneak it in there
jubilee for the earth is a timely theme
for the season of creation
one september to 4 october bishop mark
stenger of
troye's co-president of pax christie
said last month lodata see is a
monumental gift which could become
more and more our charter in the
post-coronavirus era
more and more let's sneak it in with one
sunday
and then a weekly sunday
the lutheran world federation
so now we're talking about the
protestants right how do they feel about
this
season of creation 2020 celebration
guide
the 2020 theme jubilee of the earth it's
the exact same language
exactly the same so have we merged
the two when protestantism
reaches across the gulf to take the hand
of rome
then the image of the beast will be
formed
this particular year so what are going
to do in this particular
they're going to look at the
relationship between
rest for the earth and ecological
economic
social and political ways of living
that's an integration of church and
state definitely
this particular year the need for just
and sustainable systems has been
revealed by the far-reaching effects of
the global
kovi 19 pandemic
this is fascinating so here's their
document that they produce
jubilee for the earth and there are
certain interesting points in that
document yes this document they sent
around to the
churches of the world and how they can
join in celebrating this
jubilee for the earth okay so let's have
a look at it
it's also when you look at all of these
affiliated associations
then uh it's quite quite a comprehensive
movement right
yes yeah there's the actor lines you
have the anglican
communion environmental network you have
roca
you have the global catholic climate
movement you have the world council of
churches and of course the lutheran
world federation and the world communion
of reformed churches so
they're all in there let's have a look
at some of these points
so according to this wisdom the law of
moses
included provisions for the sabbath
very prominent in their documents yes
on the seventh day of each week god's
people were free
from the need to produce or consume
so they're using jubilee language here
the rest was extended to animals
and the land itself honoring the creator
the jubilee was 49 years on the 50th
year there was
a release of all slaves
yes by allowing creation to rest
following the seventh seventh year god's
people
were to dedicate a year to this
ecological
social and economic restorative justice
a
jubilee for the earth interesting
yeah they're linking the of course the
sabbath was the seventh day
not the first day right in this
celebration guide for the season of
creation we offer resources
in the economical spirit of our common
vocation to protect the earth and
sustain
the condition for life to thrive we
encourage the entire christian family to
join us in this special time to pray
reflect take bold action to realize
a jubilee for the earth the united
nations is also
involved cop 26 is particularly
significant
as parties are due to announce how they
will implement the paris climate
agreement
and whether they will fall short uh
participate in civil action to put
pressure on governments
a church is calling for civil action
there's
quite a few actions in this report and
this is one of the
more interesting ones so they like you
just said
did jesus ever ask for civil actions
i don't think so should his followers
follow in his footsteps or should they
well we'll leave that to the to the
listener
in your wisdom you're granted a sabbath
a blessed time to rest in gratitude for
all that you have given this issue comes
up again and again
but why is it that they cannot see
that they have the wrong sabbath that
they have a papal sabbath
that is based on purely roman
power that changed the law
and they claim it is proof of their
ecclesiastical power
and yet they will use the scripture
that is astounding
we have not allowed the land to observe
her sabbath
and the earth is struggling to be
renewed
during the season of creation we ask you
to grant us courage to observe
a sabbath for our planet
it's clear where they are heading with
this it is absolutely crystal clear
opening sentences one we gather in the
image of the creator many
who is a community of love one
we gather in the name of the redeemer
many
who reconciles all of creation one
we gather in the presence of the
life-giver many
who inspires new life and renews it
yeah this is some examples that they
provide for how you can do it in your
church
in other words responsive reading it's a
kind of lectio divina
where you basically follow
blindly i i'm not a friend of
of these lectio divina where
the modus operandi of the repetitions
brings about a certain state of mind
i prefer knowing what does the word of
god say and what does it mean
yes in your wisdom you gave a sabbath
for the land to rest but these days
our living pushes the planet beyond its
limit
yes as you go through this document this
keeps on coming up
the sabbath the sabbath so is there a
movement to bring about a sabbath
i think definitely why do some people
not see it
it is amazing we pray in thanksgiving
for mother earth
in whom all life is rooted
did you know that life is rooted in
jesus christ
i am the way the truth
and the life all life
is rooted in our creator
and through him and by him were all
things created
and there is nothing that exists that
was not created by him
there is no way that i will ever bow
down
to mother earth that is idolatry
that is pantheism of the highest
order there's no way that a protestant
should ever produce
a sentence like this in any of their
documents
this is purely papal language this is
the same language as we found
in lodatusi yes pantheism at its core
brother son is there anything we can say
to that
i am lost for words i am absolutely
stunned
whose energy radiates life
sister water now i'm even more lost for
words
who nurtures and revives us and
co-creatures with whom we live and for
whom we are called to
till and keep this garden could you do a
responsive prayer to that
could you say enlighten our hearts and
remain with
your world you could also organize a
pilgrimage in a significant
ecological site or praying with
ecological
themed scripture or prayers like this
ecological rosary
while walking so we're back to
repetitive
rosary prayers i mean when i was in
catholicism
you had to every time you went and did
penance after you had confessed your
sins
you would have to read the rosary for
example
ten hail marys one our father ten el is
one our father
it's repetitive prayer the bible says do
not be like the pagans
that repeat over and over and they think
they will be heard
by their repetitive prayers that this
should come from the pen of
protestants is unbelievable
through questions you are invited to
reflect on god's presence and the
goodness of that
which you behold this
is already sounding like leola's
exercises
absolutely these are ignacion exercises
during this season of creation consider
contemplating all of these words
contemplating prayers a part of your
local ecology
this is an exercise that you can choose
to do alone or with a group
invite holy wisdom to open the eyes of
your heart who is holy wisdom here
is it brother son perhaps
become aware of god's presence this is
ignacion that's it
spirituality reflect on the ecological
cycles this is ignazian spirituality
pay attention to what you feel this is
ignacion
spirituality spiritual these are the
exercises of lyola
this is to put it bluntly
demonic yes a few years ago
i gave some lectures on this issue
they were called the jesuits and the
counter reformation
perhaps you can put those things
definitely there's two lectures actually
it's two lectures yes part one and two
what's really interesting is that the
document continues
with this statement join a mobilization
young people and their supporters from
all generations are coming together for
global
strikes in the movement known as
fridays for the future visit
fridays for the future or laudato c
generation the movement of young
catholics
for more information on the strikes
it's unbelievable to me that a
protestant organization
can call for strikes
you can urge action on climate change to
protect
biodiversity and promote jubilee for
your local ecology by holding a strike
in your community
or joining a strike that is already
planned
this is referring to those greta tanburg
strikes
that we made two videos on sunday is
coming part one and two i'll put the
links of that also
into the descriptions and the comments
below excellent
you do that it continues the season of
creation is the time of year when the
world's 2.2 billion
christians are invited to pray and care
for creation
what was the memorial to creation the
sabbath is the memorial for creation
to honor the creator of the earth and
all living things
and this is the opposite as an
economical network
we are inspired by the urgent call from
pope francis
laudato c for a new dialogue
on how we are shaping the future of our
planet
isn't it interesting that a protestant
organization
is dictated to by a roman catholic
morality
absolutely then they
close off here with the members of the
season of creation advisory committee
and
we'll see that there are very important
institutions laudato sea research
institute for example
church of england environmental working
group
world communion of reformed churches
greek orthodox
church of zimbabwe angola and a whole
lot of
others are in different denominations
all walks of life
here is another quote from the spirit of
prophecy
a letter 232 from 1899
in the 17th of revelation is foretold
the destruction of
all the churches who corrupt themselves
by
idolatrous devotion to the service of
the papacy
those who have drunk of the wine of the
wrath of her fornication
in other words incorporated her false
thinking her false ideology
her ignatian spirituality into this
system
everything we've just seen in the
previous document correct
john writes and they came one of the
seven angels which had the seven
vials and talked with me saying unto me
come heather and i will show unto thee
the judgment of the great that
sits upon many waters
with whom the kings of the earth have
committed fornication
we've seen that and the inhabitants of
the earth had been made drunk with the
wine of a fornication
constant indoctrination
so he carried me away in the spirit into
the wilderness
and i saw a woman that is a church set
upon a scarlet colored beast
full of the names of blasphemy
having seven heads and ten horns and the
woman was arrayed in purple and scarlet
decked with gold and precious stones and
pearls having a golden cup in our hand
full of the abominations and filthiness
of a fornication
the roman catholic church is the only
church in the world
that uses the symbol of the woman with
the golden cup in her hand
if you walk into the vatican and you
turn
right and you go into the first
big chamber there she stands the woman
with a cup in her hand
she is quite blatant about it
thus is represented the papal power
which with all deceivableness of
unrighteousness by
outside attraction and gorgeous display
deceives all nations promising them as
satan our first parents all
good to those who receive its mark and
all
harm to those who oppose its fallacies
the power which has the deepest inward
corruption will make the greatest
display and will clothe itself with the
most elaborate
signs of power we've seen this yeah over
and over
the bible plainly declared declares that
this covers a corrupt
and deceiving wickedness upon a for it
was the name written
mystery babylon the great the mother of
harlots and abominations of the earth
what is it that gives its kingdom to
this power
protestantism a power which while
professing to have
the temper and spirit of a lamb and to
be allied to heaven
speaks with the voice of a dragon it is
moved by a power from beneath
we are living in those times
exactly reviewing herald december 13 the
man of sin
who thought to change times and laws has
exalted himself
above god by presenting a spurious
sabbath to the world
the christian world has accepted the
child of the papacy
and cradled and nourished it thus
defying god by removing
his memorial and setting up a rival
sabbath
after the truth has been proclaimed as a
witness to all nations
every conceivable power of evil will be
set in operation
and minds will be confused by the many
voices crying
low here is christ low he is there
this is the truth i have the message
from god he has sent me with great light
then there will be a removing of the
landmarks and an attempt to tear down
the pillars of our faith
a more decided effort will be made to
exalt the false sabbath
and to cast contempt upon god himself by
supplanting the day he has blessed and
sanctified
this false sabbath is enforced by an
oppressive law
i believe we are heading that way me too
i find it astounding that they quote the
bible in the seventh day
and then translocated to the first day
of the week yes
and nobody sees it they don't and
they don't blink an eye no so basically
when we look at the developments over
the last
month we can see a steady progress
in surveillance technology
the building up of this power
the separating of the so-called dark
side and the light side
and the children of the light will be
those that run
with papal morality in all its glory
and the children of darkness will be the
deep state
those that want to tear down moral
values those that are against
religious norms and standards and
i believe those that want to have
different standards to the majority
to the common good and we
are experiencing an interesting time
and i believe we are in the final events
of this earth's history
clearly we've seen that the papal agenda
is infiltrated in all that is happening
absolutely and in the churches and in
the city and it's being accepted by the
churches
the whole protestant
world embraces this whole thing
we are definitely walking into
very serious times i believe that is the
case
and uh i think we should in our next
discussion because from what we've just
read
this is not going to just stay out there
it's going to come into our very ranks
yes i think we should talk about
the issue of the shaking yes definitely
because we've read quite a number of
quotes here
and they are aligned
absolutely with the bible this is what
the bible says in revelation chapter 13
and chapter 14 right up to chapter 17
this is the end time scenario
and if we believe that revelation is
being fulfilled before our very eyes
then it is absolutely essential
that we become serious about what we
believe
and what we preach to the outside world
so may god give us the grace yes to know
where we stand in the stream of time
and not become ostriches put our heads
into the sand
and not note the signs of the times
yes thank you very much and i just want
to also reiterate what you said earlier
it's also imperative for us not to get
involved
in these yes we are observers we are
observers we are observers
because god's people can be on both
sides of those
divides yes so we must stand
back and get the people get the message
out yet and get them out of there
to every nation to
everybody out there so that people can
make an informed choice
and say whoa are we in harmony with the
scriptures
or are we in harmony with another system
here
this is not choosing sides this is
broadcasting the final message
of warning to the world amen let's pray
will you pray for us i will pray our
heavenly father
we are very grateful
that we can be living in these times and
that we can have your support will you
please
bless us and keep us in these serious
times at our head
in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears click
and you will receive notifications
to watch the next one click here
thank you again and see you next time